all right so where to begin you gotta
give it up so much information before
this panel already we've seen guest cast
we've seen great weather and outfits
with like only one other person could
pull off so I'm actually do you guys
find yourselves when you for the
cruisers when you started with season
two did you find ourselves kind of
alternating storylines or was this whole
season designed from the beginning
season to it truthfully the beginning of
season two we were sort of terrified I
obsession the hardest thing I've ever
had to write because you know we had so
much great success in season one we were
just all terrified that we were gonna
like be one of those shows that was like
oh yeah then a great first year and then
you know fizzle out so there's a lot we
have a lot of pressure on ourselves just
but you know so many of the things we
did work again things that we had
discussed from the pilot I mean you know
when we made the pilot to our biggest
ideas was that Sarah wasn't dead and
that end of season two Oliver would wake
up in Hong Kong and you know those are
two things that we managed to get to in
season two that were things that we just
discussed casually bump start marking
myself so it's really exciting to what
about getting John back
it's funny because you know as you can
see I'm a Doctor Who fan and
but I give John with understands because
it's kind of happy with with Captain
Jack that like he was on and he said so
you have to go away for a little bit so
you can come back again you've been
better and John's like yeah I understand
that I've done that once before I'm
happy to do it again thank God and you
know we were always planning leading up
to John being a regular and in season 3
okay so mark shows me something
backstage that you guys already had
season 3 mapped out yeah actually we
have a huge set of corkboards Carroll 17
tell us it so this is gonna be all the
spoilers you're gonna get this season so
it basically seasonal shower scene on
one of those parts right but shower
scene did you say shower scene yes there
are a few me
you guys in a second you guys need a
second okay
excuse the three Matt down you kill us
with that finale but you also handle and
a happy ending you team arrow was
organized I'm guessing from that trailer
that that does not stay that way for
long
no when we thought they don't with you
know after ending season one on such a
sour note with Tommy dying and the city
in flames that people what could we do
that would surprise people in season two
we thought I think we could do that what
really shocked people was to give them a
happy ending and but so much of season
three is about you know what price
victory and you know at the beginning of
the season everyone is sort of enjoying
the peace that they that they have found
and this mark always says everything's
coming up our and you know Josephine has
always said you know the minute you give
one of your characters happiness and you
realize that there are now only forty
seven thousand tumblers that have Albert
Queen gets happy ending
so clearly Berlin either reliably took
one so one of the big things everyone
was talking about is this first date
bull gets that a second I want to know
steven season season 3 is probably you
know completely embracing this arrow
side and in a way you have been the hero
of this show you have stepped forward
with social media and reaching out to
the fans and really just being like so
accessible I feel like in the same way
that Ali has not failed the city you
have not failed this show you that's
responsible for this show as Ali feels
for Starling city oh yeah for sure it's
it's if if anything you know there were
points in the first couple of seasons
where it was a little bit more important
to you that it should've been and you
know it but look I I waited my entire
life for an opportunity like this and to
see the way that the fans of reactant I
remember sitting in this hall and this
bar you know hall or a ballroom thank
you I remember sitting in this ballroom
and making a promise to the people that
were here that we were going to work
really hard and that the show wasn't
gonna suck and that I mean that's
it sounds simple but that's that's what
drives us every day it's very clear that
a lot of the marketing automated stuff
is yeah community cast up but I just say
this will probably some of your
strongest dramatic work ever the stuff
you did this season especially Moira in
the in her press conference and
following her death was this was like
next level Steven thank you did you were
you like working with these guys to say
like let's take this guy between deeper
level no I I don't make sure that those
guys write the show but I I mean for me
we talk season by season but I always
think of it like we are shooting our 48
episode right now and we're always
trying to make 48 better than 47 47
better than 46 and there were a couple
of scenes in season 2 that press
conference scene there was a I thought a
wonderful scene in the hallway between
between Laurel and I and all the
dramatic stuff surrounding Moira's death
I create those opportunities and I was
really grateful so when they prevent
themselves I try to be ready and Colton
also pains really touching right before
you know you went to the dark side these
guys I just Charlie to get these two
together in like had these great
emotional scenes
right our first day my first time so I
guess were willing we had this really
really fun it was one of our first
things was actually our kissing was
pretty hilarious my favorite things that
we got to shoot together and I in your
head hey come on she told us to mouth to
mouth our first kiss pianist our
director asked us to do more kissy Kissy
that's the way he ordered it just like
okay you think okay you just you like
more mouth to mouth and so I grabbed his
nose and his breath straight in with
what he asked for it yes for about come
out she's amazing
so yeah it's going through something
pretty crazy right now and all I can say
is I have been
and how has it been taking her from like
fronting pretzel drop out to
supervillain love child
she's definitely a big change
I'll say that there is there's no more
Roberta Co Daisy around on tabletops
arisia I think she's gonna be a very
good cook together girl but um a
different girl definitely a different
girl than Thea that you guys saw us
season wanted to see that she was not
the girl that's coming back at season
three
did you keep the pants from the finale
did you keep those leggings from the
valley of course I did and that try
Jodie Kidd she's amazing
alright so David fatherhood community
big town
and how how is father going to change
not just the man but also his place on
Samara it looks like somebody doesn't
wandering on the front lines anymore so
very very good question a lot of
dramatic tension because yeah he's on
the stakes get higher does he stay with
the team does he leave by the way the
scene that you guys saw in the preview
where David is yelling at me and
whipping his massive arms it was almost
impossible not to flinch it's just a
great I mean it was just a great story
point Jemaine they won't bother I think
the stakes of that a lot so John you are
back
first I need to ask your co-stars what
is the runch is binky the stuntman set
so far if you say anything I'll kill you
all
why did you what do you know about with
what mr. Merlin is up to now well I was
actually just things Andrews we were
talking and he said you know if you read
the scripts and I literally just flew in
yesterday from London and I finished
which and I must say the producers have
been really really wonderful in allowing
me to do finish this stuff up that I've
had to do in the UK plus a couple of
things I have to go they were pre
contractual so thank you very much but I
get to read what I'm about to do so I'm
sitting here not going like your knowing
Adaro these guys are saying if you to
see this have you seen this I'm like I'm
gonna be in my hotel room that's part of
the excitement about episodic television
for me is almost not knowing what you're
gonna do until that script comes out
because then it's you're you know that's
the thrill of doing it is trying to
figure out how you do it but also how
you make it really believable for you
guys and also just makes it much more
fun it's more spontaneous that way
I'm assuming he survived
whatever the chest pains just gasps hey
boss
it was a mistake don't you say that
means it looks like a captain
it doesn't this man is had police career
that shot was very heroic in that clip
could you tell us anything about what he
is doing he's doing he's become like the
Commissioner Gordon a startling City
when you said it'll be any chance of us
seeing an assessment producers working
with the csi's of central city with the
woman the CSI team of central city well
that is an interesting question uh
direct that's our but you still drive
inside nice basic episode of crossing
over so it's
I wanted to sandwich see with the both
of them selling
I'll string both ium that how's that so
I had to ask about this you go ahead I
think it episode three Felicity's doing
this it episode of 1/4 of the flash
Felicity is going to show up in Central
City
Laurel Sarah how are you keeping all
these couples straight and Steven who do
you think Oliver actually come on yeah
you know one of the things we talked
about a lot is you know season three you
know is typically when shows bring on
you know some game-changing cast members
Craig used to gather wood you know it
really you know it's one of those things
that once you get season 3 when you see
the cast like you sort of can't imagine
what those first two seasons were like
without them so you know we were very
conscious of making those additions this
year and we you know we we actually
first sat down with DC we asked if we
could bring tech Oregon and
they had other plans and they said you
know she is the best so now let's talk
about Melissa t-this is this is the
thing let's talk about what can you tell
us about this situation okay really big
spoiler they go for but they you know we
weren't trying to fish I always believe
Stephen what is it like now the Titanic
has to shift a little bit right this
year they just go on a date yeah and
then we'll see what happens also
changing is the Oliver boys situation
they are now full-on sidekick
how is it how is it finding like the
Jedi Master - mister cheekbones here
yeah I gotta say it's really cool having
the second nicest student of the show
now this suits pretty bad all over and
Roy brings out parts of the Oliver Queen
character and a lot of the a lot of the
you know the smarter more sarcastic more
humorous elements of the classical
over-clean character that we are
building towards and I think that the
altar boy dynamic allows me to play a
lot of those things but there are
unresolved issues for Roy leading back
to last season so again however good
they are right now controlling and I
think that Malcolm is
to see how much he can gain control or
you know he's always been able to
control people with finance with doing
damage to them by hurting them with the
violence but he's never been able to
control emotions in a sense and that's
really you know with Tommy when he fell
in love and and became the hero you know
when he died he had no control over that
so he lost his son so yeah he's gonna go
for the emotional side to control via
and see how that works that's what I
think that's thinking and then who knows
what will happen between these two and
maybe these two plays out but you know
for me as John as the fan as the you
know that the guy that has the DC
encyclopedia lying next to his bedside
table seriously I am really looking
forward to the conflict and also fun you
know because Malcolm isn't the he's a
bad guy but he's also a smart guy and
he's got a sense of humor that's great
also that Ollie's that side has come up
with with you know with Coleman I wanna
see then becoming the boris and Natasha
of Starling city